la parole est à monsieur frédéric reiss
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre
l'annoncé de l'arrêt de production sur
le site de belfort a été un choc rude
pour les salariés d'alstom
le gouvernement semble enfin avoir
mesuré l'ampleur du problème
l'état va commander en direct 15 tgv
destinés aux lignes intercités bordeaux
marseille et montpellier perpignan
ils rouleront à 200 kilomètres à l'heure
au lieu des 320 leur vitesse commerciale
habituelle cette réponse à court terme
est d'autant plus surprenante qu'on
attendait la pérennisation des activités
d'alstom à belfort et sur les différents
sites français à l'été 2015 le
gouvernement suscitait beaucoup d'espoir
en un an 101,5 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour renouveler les
trains intercités sauf que l'état
décisionnaire sur le renouvellement du
matériel roulant
en tant qu'autorités organisatrices à
renoncer au contrat cadre signé en 2009
avec alstom et bombardier
le gouvernement a décidé un nouvel appel
d'offres synonyme de destruction
d'emploi industriel à cause des délais
et de surcoûts financiers dus à des
frais incompressibles de développement
d'adaptation et d'homologation à
reichshoffen le ralentissement actuel de
la production a été la conséquence du
trou réel de plantes charge début 2010
8000 emplois sont concernés à de
multiples reprises monsieur vivalis a
annoncé dans le cadre du projet tnt une
commande de 30 trains supplémentaires
dans le cadre du marché existe entre la
sncf et alstom
la parole de l'état sera t elle
respectée pouvez vous monsieur le
premier ministre nous confirmer la date
de cette commande
les annonces concernant le site de
belfort permettront-elles de préserver
l'excellence de la filière ferroviaire
française
merci monsieur rice la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls
monsieur le député je vous réponds bien
volontiers
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans dans
un instant également sur un dossier qui
évidemment nous a mobilisés avec michel
sapin
alain vidalis ou christophe sirugue qui
était encore ce midi à belfort
vous le savez moi sur ce sujet là je
pense qu'il faut éviter la polémique
les approximations que j'ai entendu il y
a encore un instant de la part de
responsables d'ailleurs de tous bords
vous le savez le gouvernement avait pris
l'engagement que l'activité ferroviaire
serait maintenue sur le site alstom de
belfort et avec la volonté bien sûr de
préserver et de développer l'activité
sur les autres sites et avec le plan
présenté ce matin
cet engagement est tenu il est essentiel
pour notre pays pour nos grandes
entreprises de transport pour lier airs
atp pour la sncf com pour l'avenir de la
filière et scène ferroviaire nantes fin
l'ensemble il est essentiel pour alstom
de préserver les compétences du site de
belfort pas seulement le site de belfort
mais les compétences et c'est un enjeu
majeur d'emplois et de politique
industrielle
et c'est sur la base de cette conviction
nous avons ouvert un dialogue avec
alstom après une décision qui a surpris
tout le monde et mener une concertation
étroite avec les élus locaux et les
organisations syndicales
et c'est ce travail qui a permis de
faire émerger aujourd'hui une solution
collective
le plan repose sur trois axes concret
une modernisation profonde de la
production ferroviaire de belfort un
développement des activités de services
et les investissements significatifs
pour une diversification du site
avec l'apport de l'état des
collectivités territoriales comme de
l'entreprise évidemment toute une série
de questions restent encore en suspens
vous venez
de les évoquer mais ce qui me paraît
essentiel et je veux insister c'est le
maintien de la charge de travail à
belfort et de notre avance technologique
en matière ferroviaire et qui passe par
une transformation et une modernisation
de la production sur le site cela a été
annoncé ce matin comme je me pète plus
long monsieur le député je voudrais
faire la remarque suivante il est assez
étonnant d'ailleurs il ya quelques jours
de mettre en cause le gouvernement parce
que celui-ci ne prendrait pas ses
responsabilités lui j'aurais pas son
rôle d'actionnaire ou ne j'aurais pas
son rôle tout simplement par rapport à
des entreprises d'état comme la sncf et
la ratp et d'entendre maintenant y
compris de la part d'un ancien ministre
des transports dire ou évoquer le
bidouillage
nous avons assumé nos responsabilités
comme et à aix ionnaires et sans
l'intervention de l'état en effet
monsieur le député mesdames et messieurs
les députés aujourd'hui alstom n'aurait
pas été en possibilités l'eau seulement
d'annoncer qu'il développait le site de
belfort mais de dire que d'une manière
générale alstom et donc ses salariés est
longue les sites concernés pouvaient
voir l'avenir d'une autre manière
nous assumons nos responsabilités à
chaque fois et d'ailleurs c'est assez
étonnant d'entendre cette critique parce
que je ne les ai jamais entendu par
exemple concernant rafale et dassault
c'est à dire vous avez une drôle de
vision de ce qu'est le rôle de l'état
actionnaire
qu'il assume ses responsabilités quand
il s'agit du rafale et grâce notamment à
l'action de jean yves le drian et grâce
enfin à l'exportation ce qui n'avait
jamais été fait jusqu'à maintenant et
nous assumons aussi nos responsabilités
quand il s'agit d' alstom
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur